there's a difference between the body
and the soul and if the notion of the
Soul turns you out think about
personality
you know that which is within and only
comes out how do you see a person's
personality through their actions
through their words through their
attitudes the body's really easy to see
the body can be made beautiful
pretty pretty easily too can't it uh
makeup you know it's one way of doing
that clothing you know clothing that
actually fits well makes a big
difference
um
working out exercise all those sorts of
things beautify the body
what if you want to beautify your soul
that's harder to do isn't it it's a bit
tougher to change your your personality
and some people have good personalities
and other people you know frankly I mean
you know this to be the case some people
don't have good personalities right you
wouldn't want to
be with them in a relationship long term